[MUSIC PLAYING]
TOM GRINSTED: My name is Tom.
I'm product manager on
the Google Play Console.
And I'm joined onstage by
my good friend, Tamzin--
she is head of
Business Development
for Western Europe--
and also, Dario, who is a
lead engineer on the Console
as well.
Now, the three of
us represent teams
who really have only one job.
And that job is to build
products to help people
just like you build better apps,
better games and, ultimately,
better businesses on Android
and with Google Play.
That's what we and our teams
think about, literally,
every day.
I think it's worth
saying what that actually
looks like for a second.
At its heart, what it looks like
is talking to people like you--
find out what your needs are,
find out what kind of insights
you want, take it
back to the teams,
and then pausing over
3 billion events a day
that are generated
by Google Play,
and turning all of
these events and all
of this amazing data into
metrics, insights, and tools
that you can use to
make better decisions.
Because at the
heart of the job--
and what all of you do
on a day-to-day basis
is make loads and loads of
decisions about your business,
about your acquisition,
about your development,
and about your
product road maps.
And it's our job to get you
the information you need
to make those decisions well.
Because a good
decision is founded
on good insights and good data.
This is a really big job.
The 3 billion should give
you a good idea about that.
But there are loads and
loads of different ways
you can go about it
and loads of ways
you can think about it as well.
Now, I'm sure all of
you in your companies
think about this kind
of challenge every day.
And you'll have your own
unique ways to do it.
Now, the way that Tamzin,
Dario, and I think about it
is around a mental model
of a user lifecycle.
It's probably quite
familiar to a few of you.
Now, the user lifecycle starts
with discovery and acquisition.
The first phase of
building a business
and getting a user
onto your app or game
is to get them aware of
you in the first place.
Discovery and acquisition is
all about getting in front
of the user, persuading them
that you've got a really
interesting game or app-- that
you've got a really interesting
product they want to use--
and eventually persuading
them to tap on that button--
and installing it.
After the install, I feel,
is where the fun begins.
Because after the
install you get
engagement and monetization.
This is where people
are coming back
to your products every day.
They're opening them.
They're loving them.
They're loving all the work that
you and your teams have done.
And hopefully, they're
also paying you as well.
You're monetizing.
It would be great if this
were the end of the story,
if everybody you acquired
just used you again and again
and again, and that was it.
But unfortunately, it's not.
Because very often, for almost
every user at some point
in the user lifecycle,
there's also the uninstall,
the point where someone--
for whatever reason--
decides to remove you from
their phone or tablet.
And then they
become a lost user.
It would be really sad if
this was the end of the story
as well.
But increasingly,
the user lifecycle
ends like this, with persuading
people to come back again,
persuading them to give you
a second or a third chance,
telling them about the
wonderful new features you have
that they want to try again.
This, as a sketch, is
how us and our teams
think about the
challenge in front of us.
How do we get you
the information
you need to be able to
optimize each parts of this?
As a sketch, it's
also very simple.
And it's worth saying that there
are also quite negative parts
of it as well.
So for every person
who discovers you,
there's somebody who
doesn't come across you,
who doesn't find you.
And for every person who
finds you and installs you,
there's another who--
for whatever reason--
choose not to install.
And even after that, for every
person who becomes engaged,
there's another who installs
you and doesn't use you
all the time or someone who
does but, eventually, doesn't
monetize.
And then, lastly,
for everybody who
you lose but choose
to come back,
there's another one who is
not convinced to give you
a second chance.
Now, the way to win
at this game, the way
to really optimize
your business,
is to minimize all of the bad
parts of the user lifecycle
and maximize all
of the good parts.
And that's what us
and our teams do.
We build tools and
insights to help
you make decisions to
maximize the good parts
and minimize the bad parts.
Now, the reason the
three of us are really
excited to be here today
and to talk to all of you
is because, over the last
year, since the last I/O,
our teams have been building
successively more tools, more
insights, and more
metrics to help
you build more
successful businesses
on Play and on Android.
And that's what we're going
to talk about today, some
of the exciting launches
we've made recently,
that we made this week,
and that are coming up,
to help you optimize
your user lifecycles.
So without further
ado, we're going
to start at the beginning
of the user lifecycle.
We're going to start with
discovery and acquisition.
And for that, I'm really
happy to welcome Tamzin.
TAMZIN TAYLOR: Thanks, Tom.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Tamzin Taylor.
And I work in the
Business Development
Team for Western Europe.
Now, sorry, guys.
But I think I'm actually
the luckiest person here,
because I get paid to work with
developers just like yourselves
every day.
I get to help them understand
their businesses better, help
them identify opportunities
and improve their business.
In a way, as a former
product manager,
I'm living vicariously
through their success.
But one thing which often
comes up with these partners
is the same question--
how can I improve
my discoverability?
How can I get in
front of more users?
And how can I stand
out from the crowd?
In a nutshell, how can
I get more installs?
Does this sound like something
you're interested in?
Excellent-- lots of
nodding of heads.
Well, you're in the right
spot because, in the next 15
minutes, I'm going to
cover some of the things
that we're doing
to make or maximize
your opportunities to be found.
And I'm going to go deeper
to help you understand
how your different user
acquisition channels
are making a contribution
to your bottom line.
Now, if everyone
watched the keynote,
you would have heard
David Burke talk about how
Android has billions of users.
What you might not know
is, in the last 12 months,
the number of Android
users who downloaded
a game more than doubled.
And so what?
What does this mean for you?
It means there's a huge
potential demand for your app
or game.
The question is, how do you
get in front of those users?
So we've been
working really hard
to make your app even more
discoverable and accessible.
Now, when we think
about installs,
you might think about loading
your app into the Play Store
once it's in production
and hoping for the best.
Well, what if users could
download your app or game
while you were
still building it?
What if users could tell
you that they really
wanted to download your app
or game that didn't currently
exist in the Play Store?
Well, we're working
on a couple of tools
to answer these questions.
The first is Early Access.
So Early Access is a
collection in the Play
Store of brand new Android
titles running open beta.
Those billions of users
I spoke about earlier--
they can all download apps and
games from this collection.
And the great news
is that they can
give private and actionable
feedback to the developer
before you go live.
So you can really
tweak and optimize
your app to really maximize
your chance of success
when you do go live.
The second is Pre-Registration.
With Pre-Registration, you
can put your app or game
into the Play Store.
But instead of the
Install button,
it has a
Pre-Registration button.
Now, this is fantastic.
Because that means
users can opt in
to have you tell them when your
app or game is ready and goes
into production.
So it's Pre-Registration.
We're helping support your
efforts to start marketing
before you even go live.
And it's been instrumental
for top publishers like Rovio,
who've been able to
get their fans really
excited about an
upcoming release.
Now, if any of you were
here last year at I/O,
you might recall, we
launched Instant Apps.
Instant Apps help
get your app in front
of people in more
places, more quickly,
and with less friction.
In March, at the Game
Developer Conference,
we launched Google Play Instant.
So Google Play Instant--
where users see
Google Play Instant,
they can download or
access your Instant App,
whether it's the Try
Now on the Play Store,
through browsing,
searching, or--
ah!
Thanks, Tom.
Candy Crush Saga--
I'll try that in a second.
So with Google Play Instant,
you can just tap and try a game
without having to install
the entire package.
So whether you're looking
to storm a castle with Clash
Royale or become a word master
with Words with Friends 2,
it's just a really
great way to help
users try your app or game
without the full commitment
of downloading it.
So in this way, we're trying
to help your accessibility
and your discoverability.
And it really worked
for Hothead Games.
They actually saw a 19% lift
in the number of acquisitions
after launching with
Google Play Instant.
So you can see, we're
really trying hard
to make it easier for users
to try before they buy,
improve your discoverability
and your accessibility.
But that's all well and good.
And you're in the right room.
And we might be bit biased.
But we think you can only
manage what you measure, which
is why to support the launch
of Google Play Instant
and to help you understand
the contribution
that this marketing channel
is having to your bottom line,
we're really proud to announce
brand new stats in the Play
Console, to help you measure
the success of your Instant App.
Feedback from developers
has been fantastic.
But we did get some messages
that you wanted the stats
to be more easily discoverable.
So we've put them front and
center in the Play Console.
And so now, you
can see the number
of launches and conversions
that your Instant App has had.
What's a conversion?
A conversion are
the number of times
a user who's launched
the Instant App then
goes on to download it.
And because the stats
are in the Play Console--
if you love playing
with data, you'll
love this-- it means
you can slice and dice
this information with
your other key metrics,
like installs and revenue.
So it's pretty exciting.
So you can now easily track
the success of your Instant App
on your overall growth.
And today, I'm really excited to
announce brand new capabilities
in this reporting.
You can now track which
products-- across browsers,
Search, and Play Store-- are
driving most of your Instant
App success.
So you've got Instant Apps.
And now you've got the
fantastic reporting.
Go ahead and use it.
Now, there is so
much more you can
do to increase your
discoverability on Android.
But I'm going to stop there and
say, if you want to learn more,
there's an AdWords session
on the amphitheater stage
right after this.
So I think you'll all
agree that not all
acquired users are the same.
It's really important to
acquire the right user
for your business,
the one that's
going to stick around
for a long time,
the one who's going to spend
a lot of time in the app,
and maybe the one who's going
to share your app with lots
of friends and spend money.
So it's really important
to capture the right users
for your business.
But how do you
know whether you're
attracting the right users?
How do you know whether you're
spending your time, money,
and resources in the right
places to attract those users?
And once you've
got the users, how
do you know that you're
actually doing a good job?
How do you know you're
delivering them value?
And where can you improve?
These questions sound familiar?
I hope so.
Because the great news
is, we have some updates
to the Acquisition
reports that will
help answer these questions.
They'll help you
interrogate, understand,
and optimize your user
acquisition strategies
to help your bottom line.
So let's take a look.
So when we think
about these updates
to the Acquisition
reports, we've
really tackled the
three core questions
that both myself, Tom, and Dario
hear from developers every day.
And I know some of
you have asked me
these questions quite a lot.
So the first one is, how do
people find my app or game
on the Play Store?
How valuable are
the users that I
acquire through different
marketing channels?
And how am I doing?
Can I improve?
So let's tackle the first one.
How do people find my app
or game in the Play Store?
Now, I know I've got some
partners in the audience who
I've worked with quite a lot.
And one of the questions I get
about this User Acquisition
report is, hey, Tamzin,
you know that line
that says "organic traffic"?
What is that?
Who are these users?
Where are they coming from?
Now, organic traffic-- people
who've come to your store
listing page not
through deep links--
but they might be
browsing the Play Store,
checking out Collections,
seeing new games and apps.
Or they might be looking
for a specific use case.
Like, Tom here might be looking
for apps with museum guides.
So we understand that this
is a really important channel
for you.
And for the majority
of you, it makes up
the lion's share of visitors
to your store listing page.
We also understand that
at-store optimization
is really important.
But developers like
you haven't been
able to do much with
this information to date.
It's nice to see,
but you don't really
know where they're coming from.
And you can't really
optimize for it, until now.
So in response to
all your requests,
I'm super excited to announce
the launch of Organic
Breakdowns in the User
Acquisition report
in the Play Console.
[APPLAUSE]
Yay!
Well done.
So now, you can see, for
users who've never installed
your app before, which ones are
coming from browsing the store
and which ones are searching.
Now, just imagine how
your growth or marketing
teams can leverage this
data to better present
your app or game.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
TAMZIN TAYLOR: In fact, Scopely
found the breakdown gave them
the ability to focus on
the acquisition areas that
mattered.
So what does this mean?
OK, well, let's take an example.
Let's say you all, after
this, open your laptops--
not now, I'm speaking.
And you go to the User
Acquisition report.
And you click on this Breakdown.
And you say, oh my god!
90% of my organic traffic
is coming from browse.
What should I be doing?
Well, you could probably imagine
that some of these people who
are coming from
browsing might not
be familiar with your brand,
your value proposition,
or what makes you different
from your competition.
So there's a great
opportunity there,
once you know this, to
optimize your store listing.
I'll talk more about
that in just a second.
The other great
news with this data
is that we've extended it
so you can track the users
across the whole funnel--
across subscriptions, buyers,
and retained installers.
So this really gives
you more insights
into how those two channels
are driving traffic
and what kind of users they are.
And it gets even better.
And if you're a marketing
person in the room,
I think you'll be super
excited about this.
You can now click
through and see
which search terms are driving
the most visitors to your store
listing and which convert best.
[APPLAUSE]
So that is super exciting.
It's a view into the Play
Store which we've never
been able to share before.
And it's something
you've asked us for--
let me think-- at least
3 and 1/2 years that I've
been working in this team.
So thank you to the
guys who built it.
And I really hope you find
it useful because, certainly,
our other pilot partners have.
One thing we try and do
with this information
we share with you is
make it actionable
and give you insights that
help you make better decisions,
as Tom mentioned earlier.
So we were really
happy to get feedback
from Fun Games for Free
about the relevance
of the long tail searches.
And what I love to
hear from Evernote
is how they found their
data really actionable.
Because again, we
want to give you
data that's going to help
you make better decisions
to grow your business on Play.
So developers said that
they loved this new feature.
And because we tested it
with quite a few partners,
I thought, given that
you're here today
and made the effort
to come along,
I'd share with you some of
the things which they're
going to use this
information for,
in case it sparks some
ideas in your own head.
So the majority of the
developers we tested with
said they would use
this data to evaluate
their user-acquisition
strategies.
A lot of them said they would
use it to optimize their store
listing--
so changing their descriptions,
their screenshots.
And some even said they would
redesign their on-boarding flow
so that the features, benefits,
and whatever else people are
searching for are reflected
in that first-time user
experience, to make it even
more relevant for that person
when they install the app.
So we're really pleased that our
developers found this useful.
And I hope you will as well.
And I hope that
answers your question,
how do people find my app
or game in the Play Store?
Now, the marketeers in
the room might have found
that to be super exciting.
But the next part's my favorite.
So if you care about
paying people on time,
if you care about
running a good business,
if you're a CFO or
a product manager,
you probably care about
acquiring valuable users.
Which is why we'll tackle the
next question-- how valuable
are the users that I'm acquiring
through different marketing
channels?
Now, a lot of the developers
I speak to tell me they
love the User
Acquisition report.
But installs are only
part of the story.
I'm sure you'll agree.
They tell me that retention,
purchases, and subscriptions
are leading critical indicators
of that one metric you
all care about--
revenue.
So today, we're launching a
brand new item in the Buyer
Acquisition report--
ARPU, Average Revenue Per User.
So now, you can see exactly how
much average revenue per user
you're getting from
different marketing channels.
And that includes the
organic traffic breakdown
I spoke about earlier,
Google Search,
and third-party traffic.
So if you're
responsible for setting
the user-acquisition
strategies in your business,
or you're responsible
for making sure you have
a profitable company,
this information
will help you make
the right decisions.
So no matter whether you're
running a classical CPM
model, Cost-per-Install
model, or you're driving value
further down the
funnel, we really
think this information will
help you evaluate your existing
strategies and make better
decisions moving forward.
Now, lastly on acquisition--
I know there's a few of
you in the room who always
say to me, hey, Tamzin,
how am I performing
against my competition?
How can I do better?
How can I improve?
Now, benchmarks are
really important.
And we totally
understand they're really
valuable to help you identify
where the room for opportunity
is versus the market and where
you're already smashing it out
of the park and
doing a great job.
In other words,
benchmarks are great,
because they can help
you focus your investment
on the items which will
give you the best return.
So for all these
reasons, we were
really happy a month ago to
launch the Retained Installers
benchmarks in the User
Acquisition funnel.
So now, for all
organic traffic, you
can easily see, throughout
the user journey,
from in-store
conversion all the way
through to 30-day retention,
exactly where the opportunities
are for you to improve or
where the efforts you've had
have really paid off.
And we've got a lot
of happy developers
who've tested this with
us, including Intuit
and Not Doppler, who've
used it to really tweak
their conversion and
get improvements there
or, in the case of Not
Doppler, finding out
that, actually, all the
efforts that they put in
have really paid off.
One thing I mentioned
earlier that I
love about this feature and all
these User Acquisition reports
is that they're not
just here to tell you
where you're going wrong.
They're here to give
you a reference point
and give you confidence in
your decision-making, which
is why I was really happy to
see the quote from Playdots, who
told us that they love the extra
validation and confidence they
get on their own
decision-making.
So the new tools that
we've launched help you get
discovered.
Instant Apps and
Pre-Registration
get your apps in front of
users like never before.
And if you talk
to us, we'll say,
the most important
thing about this
is we've launched new reporting
to help you optimize for it.
Updates to the User
Acquisition reports
give you the data
that you've never
had before to make
much better informed
decisions around your app store
optimization, your acquisition
investment, and to really
help you drive and acquire
more valuable users.
Right-- so now you
have the right users.
But how are you going
to keep them engaged?
And how are you going
to monetize them?
Well for this exciting
part of the talk,
let me hand over to my
esteemed colleague, Dario.
DARIO FRENI: Thanks, Tamzin.
[APPLAUSE]
It's great to be here.
So new tools help
you get discovered.
And the acquisition
insights help
you find and acquire more
and more valuable users.
But what about helping you
in the next stage of the user
lifecycle journey, like
engagement or monetization?
How can we help you engage your
user more and earn more money
from them?
I'm glad to say that
we have some new tools
to help with that.
So first off,
earlier this year, we
launched the Events timeline.
The Events timeline gives you
contextual information close
to Charts in the
statistics page,
in the Android Vitals dashboard,
in the Subscription dashboard,
and other Chart surfaces
on the Play Console,
showing you key events
that may affect your apps,
such as-- for example--
the rolling out
of a new release.
This way, you can quickly spot
correlations between changes
in metrics and such key events.
For example, you can
understand whether a changing
average rating correlates with
a rollout of a new release
or whether a price
change is affecting
and how it's affecting the
average revenue-per-user.
Or if you use Instant App--
if an Instant App
configuration change,
such as mobile holdback,
is affecting your sessions
positively or negatively.
Early adopters of these
features loved it.
One developer in
particular told us
that they were able
to quickly understand
why a certain metric spiked
in a certain country.
So the Events timeline helps
you solving these mysteries
quicker, without having to
dig into other dashboard
or other data.
Once you have
acquired your user,
you might want to
check how users
are engaging with your app.
Firebase offers great tools
specifically for this purpose.
In particular, Google
Analytics for Firebase
can be enabled just by linking
the analytics SDK to your app
and signing up to the
service, of course.
And out of the box, it
will give you, already,
meaningful metrics about
engagement and retention
of the users.
What's also
interesting is that you
can instrument your app,
instrument your code
to track the features that
matter the most to your app.
Another really cool feature
that the Firebase team
launched earlier this year
is Firebase Predictions.
Firebase Predictions
uses data coming
from analytics and our
machine-learning knowledge
and tools to give
you predictions
about how your users are
going to behave in your app.
And like Google Analytics, just
by enabling, out of the box,
you will get predictions about
a user's spend and user churn.
And you can take some
actions on these predictions.
And similarly, you can
also instrument your app
to get more personalized
prediction that you care about.
If you want to learn more about
Google Analytics for Firebase,
you can check out the session
later today on stage 6.
So our friends Steve, Mai, and
Russ from the Firebase team
will present the latest
features of Google Analytics
for Firebase.
There is an entire truck
for Firebase tools.
So I encourage you to check
it out if you're interested.
In particular, for
Firebase Prediction,
there were two
sessions yesterday
that, in case you've
missed, they are already
available on YouTube.
Right-- so the Events
timeline gives you key events
and lets you correlate
them with your metrics.
Firebase gives you insight
and machine-learning
driven predictions about
behavior of your user.
Let's dive more now into
the monetization phase
which, after all, is probably
the most critical phase,
because it's where you earn
the money and your business
actually starts succeeding.
We've done a lot
of work recently,
especially on subscriptions.
So I'm going to
present the latest
things that we launched there.
Last year, at I/O, we launched
the Subscription dashboard.
Loads of developers use
the Subscription dashboard
on a regular basis.
We are, in fact, really
proud that the majority
of top-earning
subscription businesses
actually use this dashboard
on a regular basis, too.
But we heard that
you wanted more.
So this is why, yesterday, we
launched additional features
in their Retention and in
the Cancellation reports.
Let's take a quick look.
So in the new
Retention report, we
have re-designed it to make it
super easy to compare cohorts;
evaluate key features,
like free trials;
and also track the data
that are important to you,
like renewals.
The new Cohort selector allows
you to pick groups of users,
selecting them by SKUs,
date, and/or country.
So you can really concentrate
on a group of subscribers
and analyze their performance.
For example, you can pick
SKU with a free trial
and compare it with an SKU
with an introductory price
and see which one
of the two earns you
more revenue over time.
Or you can also focus on last
year's big marketing push
and compare it with this
year's and see which
one performed better for you.
Advanced Cohort
Comparison enables
you to explore all of
these kind of intricacies.
That's not all, though.
We've extracted key
data that we know
you're interested in to
make it easier than ever
to track conversion.
Because conversion-- that's
actually what matters to you.
So free trial success
rate and other information
about performance are
available right there
on the Subscription dashboard.
And because you know that
subscription businesses live
on repeated payments,
we also tell you,
for each cohort
you selected, which
billing periods they reach.
On today-- Cancellation report.
We also made major
updates there to help you
reduce your subscription churn.
So users can cancel
for many reasons.
And we extracted the
key technical ones out.
But as we announced yesterday,
we now show the users a survey
when they cancel, so
that they can explain why
they're cancelling.
And the results
of this survey are
available on the
Subscription dashboard.
So you will have more
qualitative insights
directly from the
users about why
they are canceling their
subscription with your service.
Lastly, we're reporting
on win-back features,
like Account Hold and Grace
Period which, by the way,
you should check out
if you haven't already.
Because we heard from
developers that it really helped
them and increased their
retention of their subscribers.
So these major updates help
your subscription businesses,
like hopefully some of
you here in the audience,
to better understand
and optimize
monetization, such a key
part of the user lifecycle.
There was a session
yesterday by our friends
Larry, Angela, and Nico about
the newest advanced Google Play
features for subscriptions,
specifically.
So if you are
interested, you might
want to check that
as well on YouTube.
So lastly, as Tom
introduced at the beginning,
the last two phases
of the user lifecycles
are uninstall and win-back.
Play Console provides you
with reports about uninstall.
So for example, daily uninstall
metrics or the uninstall events
metrics.
Or the Retained Installers
acquisition report,
in which you can check how long
users keep your app installed
before uninstalling.
But we heard you want more.
And we understand why.
Because this is such
a critical phase,
especially as your
business grows.
And also, we don't have
enough information for you,
at the moment, for win-back.
So I'm happy to say that we are
working hard on this aspect.
And we will introduce,
later this year,
some more [INAUDIBLE]
specifically
for these steps of the
user lifecycle journey.
So for example, you
will be able to analyze
how many unique users
are uninstalling
your app over a certain
selected time period
and also how many users are
installing your app again,
after having uninstalled it
at some point in the past.
So stay tuned for more updates.
So this concludes our
overviews of how Play Console
and Firebase can help you
analyzing your user lifecycle
journey.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
And now, back to Tom.
TOM GRINSTED: Thanks, Dario.
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, again.
So as Dario and Tamzin
shared, the teams
have been working really hard
to build more tools, more
insights, and more metrics to
help you run better businesses,
build larger apps,
and have happier
and larger number of gamers.
All of this work, I
think it's fair to say,
we're extremely proud of--
deeply proud of the
teams who delivered it.
But all of this work also, in
some ways, causes a problem.
Because we also understand that
all of you are really busy.
You've got so many tools, both
provided by us and others.
There are loads of
different places you can go
and loads and loads
of calls on your time.
We understand that you're busy.
And we understand
that you need it
to be easy to see what the
Console has to offer you
and what's important and
what can be passed over.
We understand this problem.
That's why I'm really happy
to say that yesterday we
launched the new Apps dashboard
in the Google Play Console.
Let's take a really quick
look at what it's like.
The Apps dashboard
is the landing page.
You sign into the Console.
You land here if
you select an app.
It gives you an overview
of all of your key data.
Now, previously, there
wasn't quite enough data.
We heard that from all of you.
And it wasn't really
well-organized.
And we've changed all of that.
To start with, we've introduced
really, really easy-to-see
trending information.
So if you want to know
if your installs are
moving in the right
direction, it's
now super easy to see that.
If you want to take
a quick look to see
if your technical
performance is going well
and your crashes are reducing,
you can see that really
easily as well.
So trends-- first thing--
really easy to glance at.
Secondly, we understand
and we heard from you
that a lot of data
belongs together.
Installs and uninstalls
should be displayed together.
You might want to take a look
at your revenue and your RPU
at the same time.
To answer that challenge, we've
sectionalized the dashboard.
We've added a load
more information.
But we've also put
it into context.
So if any of the questions
down the left-hand side
of the screens feel
familiar, these
are the questions the
dashboard specifically
asks and specifically answers.
Now, I'm sure that many of you
are reading these and thinking,
you know what?
That one's really
important to me.
I don't know--
I'm a QA.
And I really, really
want to understand
what people think of
my app through reviews
and how my technical performance
with [INAUDIBLE] is going.
But maybe you care slightly less
about how your preregistration
campaign is going.
Or maybe, on a day-to-day basis,
you don't look at revenue.
We understand that having
all of this on your dashboard
is sometimes overwhelming.
And sometimes,
frankly, not all of it
is relevant to all of you.
That's why the new dashboard
is also customizable.
Because every section you
see on the dashboard can now
be expanded or collapsed.
So if you're specifically
interested in your revenue,
you can have that section open.
And it will give you
more useful information.
And if you're less interested
in preregistration,
you can have that
section collapsed.
We remember your preferences.
So it stays exactly
as you leave it.
It's a really
lightweight way of making
the dashboard work for each and
every one of you personally.
We've been testing this,
as we test everything.
And a lot of the developers
who we've been working with
were really happy
with the changes.
I think, if I'm honest, as
a PM, I'm not sure quite
how to take this quote.
But the lead engineer
from Blue Apron
was really, really happy
that there was a simple place
to direct their product
manager so they could
see the questions that they
always ask really easily
answered by the dashboard.
And similarly, DocuSign--
very busy people--
were really happy with the
customization that we give--
customization that doesn't
completely remove things.
There's no fear of missing out.
But it does mean that
the dashboard is focused
for what you need right now.
That's a really short
overview of all of the changes
we made to the App dash.
And hopefully, when
you log in today
and you see the
new board, you'll
be able to see all of
that and how it helps you
in your day-to-day
lives and, frankly,
how it helps you see
the metrics and insights
that the Console has to
offer to really help you.
So just to round up
about where we are,
Dario, Tamzin,
myself, and our teams
think about the user lifecycle.
And we think about all
the different tools
that we can build
to help you optimize
every stage, from
Instant Apps and Pre-reg
for discovery and
acquisition through to brand
new subscription reports,
enhanced acquisition
reports, the new Events
timeline, and even
the uninstall stats and
more information coming soon
about win-back.
We think that all of
this taken together
will really help
drive your success.
And ultimately, your success
is what we work towards.
That's what we're here to help.
And all of this--
and other things, like your
technical performance--
are wrapped together with
the App dashboard as well.
So we're almost at the
end of our time together.
And there are just a couple
of more things to say.
First off, we really
want your feedback.
So if you liked the session--
and even if you didn't--
then log onto the
URL and tell us
what you thought,
because it helps
us make these sessions better
year after year after year.
And lastly, thank you
so much for listening.
From Tamzin, Dario,
the teams, and myself,
it's great see so
many of you here.
And thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]